je poursuis avec notre analyste à québec
michel pépin que vous entendez
régulièrement à la radio michel martin
disait que les augmentations ne sont
jamais populaires c'est même
politiquement assez risqué non à
quelques semaines d'un budget minceur
c'est très risqué
est ce pour ça que le gouvernement
couillard ne veut pas le faire seulement
ils souhaitent avoir l'appui des autres
partis pour ne pas porter l'odieux d'une
mesure de jambes mais c'est sûr qu'avec
le budget qui s'en vient qui prévoit des
mesures d'austérité encore plus
importante
et déjà on sait que des augmentations de
tarifs pour les cpe il y en a pour
l'électricité qui s'en vient et les
propositions d'augmentation de salaire
c'est nul on du côté du secteur public 0
la première année 0 % la deuxième année
alors dans ce contexte là c'est
extrêmement difficile pour le
gouvernement et même pour les autres
partis politiques la dalle est d'aller
de l'avant avec ce genre de mesures là
ça risque d'être assez mal perçu
n'empêche michel déterré aujourd'hui un
rapport vieux de deux ans la coïncidence
avec toute la sphère ball dieu que
n'échappe à personne
il s'est vraiment cousu de fil blanc
c'est très clair que c'est c'est
monsieur bolduc qui est à l'origine de
ce remaniement qui est à l'origine de
cette consigne du silence est maintenant
de cette proposition de loi pour changer
la rémunération des députés mais il faut
aussi se poser une question là c'est
tout ça et à coût nul donc ça coûterait
pas plus cher mais ça ne coûterait pas
moins cher non plus alors c'est tout une
opération qui sera extrêmement difficile
à mener entre les différents partis
politiques qu'on essaie de mettre de
l'avant le plus simple ce serait
certainement d'abolir la location de
départ mais le gouvernement marois
l'avait proposé le parti libéral avait
refusé déjà alors le parti libéral veut
encore qu'on examine ça de façon globale
la rémunération ce sera tout un exercice
très difficile à accomplir
ça s'annonce ardue déjà merci beaucoup
michel je vous en prie est resté là ça
devrait vous intéresser parce que denis
martin chabot à vérifier lui si c'est
possible d'abolir ces fameuses
allocation de transition et quelles sont
les règles
ailleurs au pays
c'est la seule façon d'entre eux
beaucoup à faire avancer le sujet je
suis content de voir que les échos
positifs parmi nos collègues
parlementaires sur cette question là il
faut continuer à travailler à paris le
premier ministre philippe couillard
parle encore de rémunération des députés
et de la prime de transition dont a
notamment bénéficié le ministre
démissionnaire de l'éducation yves
bolduc prime que certains voudraient
abolir
est ce possible vérification faite
oui ça s'est fait ailleurs mais il ya eu
des ratés en ontario où le régime de
pension des élus a été aboli en 1995 il
y a encore une prime de départ pour les
députés cette prime a soulevé de la
contreverse récemment quand un député
néo démocrate aurait pu toucher 58 mille
dollars après avoir siégé seulement cinq
mois
ce dernier a finalement renoncé à sa
prime
l'alberta qui a éliminé sa caisse de
retraite pour les élus en 1993 aboli ces
généreuses indemnités de départ en 2012
par contre 15 députés élus avant 2012 et
qu'ils ne brigueront pas les suffrages
aux prochaines élections pourraient
toucher en tout 5 millions de dollars au
fédéral le député qui n'a pas siégé
assez longtemps pour avoir droit aux
régimes de retraite peut obtenir une
indemnité de départ équivalente à la
moitié de sa rémunération
lorsqu'il est défait ou quitte la
politique à la fin de son mandat il n'ya
pas droit lorsqu'il quitte pendant son
mandat
à moins que ce soit pour des raisons de
santé ici des libertins chabot radio
canada montréal